So, forward search simply means you start with a feature. Let's see
if I can draw a picture. So in forward search, you simply
start with a feature, of your end features. You look at all
of your features in isolation. Let's imagine we have five features. And I
say well, I'm just going to pass you the first feature. Pass the
first feature to the learning algorithm, I get a score. Then the
second feature, then the third feature, then the fourth feature to the
fifth feature. And which ever one of those features is best, I keep.
So let's say it's the first one over here. So now
I keep the first feature. And then I say, well now that
I'm given the first feature, let's look at each of the remaining
features and see if I add them, which one does best. So,
I end up with one, two, three, four, five. I pick
the best one. And let's say that turns out to be feature
one. And then I look at feature one in combination with two
and combination with three and in combination with four and in combination
with five. Whichever one has the highest score that's the one
I move forward. And so that would be let's say in this
case worked out to be feature five and now that I
have these two features, I pick a third feature of the ones
that are remaining, two, three and four. And whichever one of
those in combination with one and five I add next, and let's
just say that turns out to be feature three. But it
turns out the error, or the score that I get for adding
the third feature to one and five, isn't significantly
better than just having one and five, and so
I stop here and say, that's the subset of
features that I would take. Does that make sense?
>> Yeah, that seems like a really neat idea and I could
see that as being a kind of efficient polynomial way of searching this
space. Though couldn't, could I think of it as a kind of hill
climbing, though? Where, where my neighborhood
relation is basically adding, one more feature?
>> Sure. Absolutely. And if it's only adding one more feature,
that's exactly what you're doing. You are doing a kind of,
a kind of hill climb. So, in fact, the, alternative, or
the sort of complement to forward search is backward search. And
backward search is, I think, by the way, you describe it
as exactly another kind of hill climbing. We're here we start
out with all of the features, and you say which one
can I eliminate, so I try one, two, three, four. I try
one, two, three, five. I try one, two, four, five.
I try two, three, four, five, and whichever four work
out best are the ones that I keep in the
second round, at let's just say that turns out to be
one, two, three, and five. And then I see, well,
of the remaining four, which one can I eliminate and still
have the best score? And I keep doing that until
I get down to a subset that still does pretty well.
So let's say I get to this case, and it
turns out, you know what? One, two, and five do bet,
just, almost as well as one, two, three, and five. But
once I go to just one and five, it does much
worse and so I'm going to stick with that. So here
you're right, I liked the way you described this, Michael, as
hill climbing. Here I'm doing hill climbing, except my neighborhood is
removing a, a single point instead of adding a single point.
>> Yeah, that's
cool. It's, for some reason, reminding me of like making it team,
like you could, I could imagine tryouts where you put everybody on
the field and you have them play, and whoever's helping the least,
you kick them off the team, so that's kind of the backward
case. We just keep kicking people out until we have the team
we want. And then the forward case is kind of like the
dream team model where you start off saying, I got nobody let's
take the best person around, add that person to my team. And,
keep doing that until we have a full set of players.
>> Okay. So this all makes sense?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Just for, just to summarize, filtering
algorithms don't necess, while they do, then can take
advantage of a label they don't really care
about the learner. And so you have to come
up with criteria that all probably makes sense,
like the ones you came up with. Information gain,
entropy variance, and you can tell stories for
why all of these make sense. This by the
way is where your domain knowledge comes in. It's the choice
of the criterion or the optimization function that, that you're using.
But they have a problem in that they don't actually take
advantage of the bias of the learner, where wrapping definitely takes advantage
of the bias of the learner. And then you just hit,
simply have a question of how to deal with the exponential
search problem by doing, I think in all of these cases,
what looks a lot like hill climbing. You just have different methods
for thinking about how to do the hill climbing.
Do you add variables, or remove variables, or do you
do some kind of random search. But ultimately, in both
cases, you have some function you're trying to optimize over.